[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur france 3 la
chaîne des municipales comme chaque soir
nous bouleverse on au programme pour
vous proposer un débat avec les
principaux candidats des villes encore
en lice en franche comté avant le
deuxième tour dimanche
et ce soir je reçois les candidats à la
mairie de belfort la deuxième ville de
franche comté sur ce plateau damien
meslot mère l'est républicain sortant
vous êtes candidat à un second mandat
mathilde nassar candidate d'une liste
soutenue notamment par europe ecologie
les verts et la france 1 soumise à vos
côté samia jaber conseillère municipale
sortante ancienne du ps du mrc vous êtes
aujourd'hui divers gauche et marie josé
fleury candidate soutenue vous par le
mouvement démocrate bonjour à tous les
quatre le 15 mars on va voir les
résultats c'est damien meslot qui est
arrivé largement en tête du premier tour
avec 48% des suffrages vous devancé dans
l'ordre mathilde nassar 15,3 samia jaber
12,9 et marie josé fleury 10,2
la socialiste marcheuse mode clavequin
est éliminé de même que le communiste
bertrand chevalier et le candidat de
lutte ouvrière jean marie pheulpin pas
de fusion donc pas de désistement à
belfort les quatre candidats qualifiés
se sont maintenues et son dock autour de
cette table alors mesdames messieurs je
voudrais d'abord savoir ce que cette
crise a changé pour vous est-ce que vous
avez modifié votre programme est ce que
vous avez modifié vos priorités pour
belfort
samia jaber le tirage au sort vous a
désigné pour commencer alors bien sûr
nous avons vécu quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire donc nous avons dû
adapter aussi le programme que nous
proposons sur le 2ème tour parce qu'en
réalité c'est une nouvelle élection et
ce qui se passera après cette pandémie
nous ne le connaissons pas encore
complètement par contre nous avons
considéré que le programme que nous
avions présentées au premier tour ac
c'est une priorité sur la question de
l'emploi et la crise économique qui
arrivent nous montre aussi que c'est un
sujet qui sera encore d'actualité
nous avons également privilégier la
question d'éducation nous avons
annoncé que l'éducation serait la
priorité de notre mandat et nous l'avons
vu pendant ces périodes de confinement
comment il a été difficile pour les
familles de tenir l'éducation et
l'enseignement pour leurs enfants
et puis bien sûr la protection parce que
les français dans cette épidémie ont
montré qu'ils avaient aussi besoin et
une attente d'une forte protection de
l'état mais aussi des collectivités
locales alors on va y revenir on
poursuit ce premier tour de table marie
josé fleury seine crise sanitaire qu'est
ce qu'elle a changé pour vous et
peut-être aussi pour votre programme
pour belfort
c'est vrai qu'on a réadapté quelques
points du programme on avait beaucoup
centré effectivement sur l'économie mais
je crois que c'est plus que jamais
d'actualité dans cette danse être après
crise dans ce dans ce moment d'ailleurs
on est toujours en crise sanitaire faut
quand même pas l'oublier et je pense que
ça aussi recentrer un certain nombre de
réflexions de toute l'équipe mais
également de façon plus générale on va
dire sur tout ce qui est proximité
humanité sur lidar it et je pense que
c'est des mots qui ont qui ont été
évoqués ses cris du coeur vite
finalement même si je pense
qu'effectivement dans quelques temps
parce que on ne peut pas tirer un
premier bilan
encore un je pense qu'il va falloir
passer un trimestre peut-être à semestre
pour voir économiquement socialement
quels sont les bouleversements que cela
entraîne
mais je crois très concrètement que dans
un premier temps on a fait une espèce de
poses très particulière on n'avait
jamais connu ça alors certains
spécialistes dit que ça arrive tous les
60 ans on se pose la question mais je
pense que ça et je l'espère chez nos
concitoyens est en tout cas dans notre
liste fait réagir sur les valeurs en
tout cas les valeurs humaines les
valeurs d'humanité les valeurs de
solidarité et de partage et dans le
monde d'après je pense qu'il va falloir
beaucoup de se poser de questions en
tout cas sur la façon dont nous vivons
et dont nous faisons les choses
mathilde nasa alors est ce que ça a
changé pour vous et pour votre programme
alors déjà pour moi ça a changé beaucoup
dans ma façon de travailler dès le
lendemain du premier tour je suis
enseignante il a fallu que j'assume la
continuité pédagogique le lien avec les
élèves leur
famille c'était très important et puis
aussi d'un point de vue personnel de
l'école à la maison pour mes enfants
alors bien sûr politiquement on n'a pas
cessé de travailler nous à 2020 en
commun pendant cette période on a
proposé une boîte à outils 35 mesures
pour le déconfinement et pour l' après
notre programme s'articule et déjà
autour de trois piliers très fort
écologie solidarité démocratie
est ce que cette crise a montré c'est
qu'en fait il fallait aller encore plus
loin
l'écologie on l'a vu la nature est
revenu en ville et puis tout le monde a
compris le lien entre le la nôtre nos
modes de vie et puis la généralisation
de ce type du pan de ce type de pandémie
la solidarité il a fallu pallier sur le
terrain les défaillances de l'état
heureusement que la solidarité existait
mais il ya des quartiers où elle n'a pas
été peut-être suffisante et la
démocratie on a été soumis aux décisions
d'un seul on a vu à quel point le besoin
de délibération collective était
particulièrement important envers drain
sur certains de ces points ont fini ce
premier tour de table damien meslot pour
vous la crise alors vous êtes maire
sortant donc vous avez aussi été amené à
gérer un peu un peu beaucoup ça comme
tous les maires en place qu'est ce que
ça a changé et peut-être aussi qu'est ce
que ça a changé sur votre vision à venir
pour belfort
si vous voulez on s'est aperçu que
pendant cette crise la france est tenu
essentiellement grâce aux collectivités
territoriales sans les collectivités
territoriales nous aurions été démunis
nous l'avons vu sur les masques nous
l'avons vu sur l'aide aux personnes nous
avons mis en place un service qui
s'appelait alors course nous le voyons
sur l'économie aujourd'hui nous avons
décidé de mettre en place avec le
conseil régional
un fond des deux entreprises en
difficulté nous sommes en train de
réfléchir également abaissé la cfe sur
certains secteurs d'activité avec une
aide sur les entreprises se basant sur
nous nous ne l'avons nous ne l'avons pas
augmenté nous avons simplement enlever
un certain m vous voyez vous avez même
du mal vous parlez de démocratie vous
avez du mal à laisser quelqu'un qui n'a
pas la même opinion que vous s'exprimer
alors on est sur une nouvelle jeunesse
urd et que les damien messieurs dont le
coup
je l'avais augmenté mais répondait alors
je n'ai pas actuellement est ce que vous
avez augmenté mais si vous me permettez
de répondre je n'ai pas l'intention de
tomber dans un
c'est qu'il y avait un certain nombre
d'exonérations qui favorisait les
grosses entreprises par rapport au petit
chez supprimés j'ai supprimé le taux de
ces feux je vous mets au défi le taux de
ces feuilles reste elle-même avant et
après et donc lavées vous avez les
supprimer des échelons immatriculations
ans et aux téléspectateurs celle ci
permet des exonérations qui favorisait
les grosses entreprises par rapport aux
petits
voilà c'est dans l'es6 nous avons été et
on laisse finir et la parole circule
rage vous pouvez si vous me laissez
terminé je pourrais expliquer hélas ce
que nous allons faire nous allons donner
des exonérations de cf
grâce à une aide de l'état l'état
donnera une partie nous donnerons le
reste sur des secteurs qui ont été
particulièrement touchés je pense à
l'hôtellerie je pense à la restauration
voilà un certain nombre de secteurs qui
pourront bénéficier de ces baisses de
ces feux donc ce que nous avons fait
nous avons assuré la protection de nos
populations de notre économie pendant
cette crise marie josé fleury je
rappelle vous êtes commerçant donc vous
êtes concerné vous connaissez bien la
question allez-y tout à fait sûr la
sieff d'ailleurs dès le départ dès le
mois de janvier on avait dénoncé en fait
cette augmentation des bases locatives
qui chez les petits commerçants qui ont
des petits chiffres d'affaires ont fait
augmenter mais drastiquement la cfe on a
des augmentations je veux dire ça y est
enfin
écoutez monsieur meslot on a eu des
augmentations 200 à 270 % chez la
plupart des commerçants
certains aujourd'hui se pose vous avez
tous mais ce sont les bases elle dit ce
sont les bases
hochtief qui ont augmenté non ça c'est
son sens en tout adhérent enlever les
exonérations monde sait très bien
6 attendez attendez on va se mettre
d'accord ces bois qui anime ce débat si
vous parler ensemble on vous coupe les
migrants parce que de toute façon c'est
inaudible personne ne comprend marie
josé fleury à l'isi en fait même si le
cette cfe est à 29,5 c'est beaucoup trop
mulhouse est beaucoup plus bas que nous
montbéliard est beaucoup plus bas que
nous donc ça ne favorise pas les
installations marie josé fleury dans la
douleur sur cette question je vais vous
donner la parole samia jaber pour
conclure rapidement
du coup c'est une bonne chose que le
qu'il y ait une aide sur la cf
avec ce levier là pour les commerçants
aujourd'hui en difficulté elle est
vitale elle est vitale certains
commerces aujourd'hui sont très en
difficulté dans certains secteurs on le
voit notamment dans les grandes chaînes
au niveau national il ne faut pas se
leurrer ses difficultés nationales vont
redescendre en local
et si effectivement de ce côté là rien
n'est fait d'autant plus que monsieur
meslot a en plus en juin 2019
ajouter la taxe locale sur les anciennes
l'extérieur donc ça remis une nouvelle
taxe
ça a remis une nouvelle taxe a été votée
en conseil municipal vert est une élue
municipale elle va pouvoir nous dire ce
qu'il en est je ne relancerait pas le
débat nous avons déjà eu ce débat au
grand belfort au moment où monsieur mais
cela fait le choix d'augmenter l'acf
nous l'avions alertés sur le fait que ça
les impacts et beaucoup plus de petites
entreprises et de commerce qui ne le
pensait et les commerçants et les
artisans qui ont reçu une augmentation
de l' or c'est faux
il ya récemment vont apprécier donc
l'analyse monsieur monsieur je voudrais
juste rappeler que pendant cette
pandémie
yahoo il y a eu aussi une rupture
d'égalité entre les candidats
parce que nous étions entre deux tours
d'une élection municipale et il ya des
candidats qui ont bénéficié de l'argent
public pour pouvoir agir je pense par
exemple à tous les maires sortants tout
à fait où monsieur mais cela renvoie un
magazine dans toutes les boîtes aux
lettres de belfort où il explique qu
tout ce qu'il a fait pendant ces deux
mois
je pense qu'il ya eu une rupture
d'égalité je les dénoncer jamais dans
les périodes précédentes avec les
prédécesseurs
meslot il n'y avait de communication
institutionnelle pendant la campagne
électorale il a refusé de l'entendre il
a fait le choix d'utiliser les deniers
publics pour sa propre campagne
mathilde nassar je vous redonne la
parole pour répondre damien meslot mais
mathilde la nasa moi j'aimerais qu'on
ait vues sur les questions de fond et je
vais revenir sur la question du commerce
bien évidemment qu'il faut supprimer
cette augmentation de l'acfe mais je
pense qu'il ya des choses qu'on pouvait
faire aussi très rapidement là pour les
commerçants je pense par exemple à la
suppression des droits de place par
exemple de les redevances dues à
l'occupation du domaine public qui sont
des choses que nous on propose de faire
très très rapidement pour aider les
commerçants et puis mettre en oeuvre par
ce fait les bases d'une coopération
future fructueuse et qui n'a pas existé
ces six dernières années
alors la crise du coc vide elle est
aussi elle a aussi été symptomatique à
belfort des difficultés des grosses
entreprises et de l'industrie avec on
l'a suivi sur cette antenne general
electric qui a souhaité délocaliser une
partie de la production en retard effet
d'aubaine dénoncent certains que peut
faire le maire que doit faire le maire
dans ces circonstances face à une
direction étrangères on le rappelle mais
d'une industrie avec un nombre d'emplois
très conséquents pour votre ville
allez-y marie josé fleury et puis la
parole tournera alors c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas entendu beaucoup monsieur meslot
sur sur general electric ces derniers
temps et c'est déplorable
vous pouvez sourire effectivement ça
vous fait rire moi je trouve ça plutôt
aberrant parce que vous avez beaucoup
plus vrai quand un moment donné il
fallait devant les caméras de télévision
pour dénoncer ce qui se passait là en
tout cas je pense que ça aurait dû
pourtant alerté je veux dire on connaît
de general electric
on sait qu effectivement d'autres
entreprises et c'est là où je vous
disais tout à l'heure
qu'en fait je pense que cette crise du
coc vide non seulement s'arrête ça aura
été pour certaines entreprises un effet
d'aubaine
mais ça va permettre à d'autres de
saisir cette opportunité pour vraiment
faire des licenciements massifs - c'est
ce qui est réellement m'inquiète le plus
et c'est là où si vraiment vous vous
êtes un acteur et un élu de terrain un
liant entre les différents partenaires
partenaires sociaux économiques
associatifs vous devez avoir un tissu je
dirais très étoffé pour prévoir
justement ces difficultés économiques
on est dans un bel ford en une dans une
région de mono industrie dans une
où l'industrie de l'énergie prime il est
donc primordial de saclay à avoir des
entreprises innovantes parce qu'on a un
savoir-faire ce savoir faire c'est
alstom
on a la possibilité de développer
l'hydrogène je parle de l'hydrogène
verts bien bien évidemment pendant le
décarbonés et là je pense que en allant
chercher en ayant les bons outils
les bons relais sur le terrain on peut
s'atteler à faire venir de vrais
investisseurs et de vraies entreprises
innovantes sur notre territoire ce qui
n'est pas fait depuis six ans samia
jaber
il a montré que notre
désindustrialisation poser problème
alors sur le dossier general electric le
problème problème à nous c'est que le
maire a réagi et n'a pas agi parce qu'il
a été prévenu évidemment des risques qui
faisaient depuis 2010 est il a fait le
choix de ne pas l'entendre sur
l'économie globalement on peut discuter
du bilan de monsieur muscle parce qu'on
n'en parle pas beaucoup de son bilan
alors il a été en effet beaucoup devant
les caméras lors de la crise mais ça
cache tout le reste parce que son bilan
économique est bien maigre
je pense par exemple le dos et
d'injonctions le centre d'affaires de la
jonction aujourd'hui c'est combien
monsieur meslot de déficits cumulés ces
6 millions d'euros sur la jonction
l'ensemble des sociétés qui gère ce parc
d'activités on n'entend jamais parler
sur la question de l'airé urbaine
monsieur mais ce a fait le choix de
tourner le dos à l'airé urbaine alors
que nous nous pensons que c'est à cette
échelle là que peut se construire le
développement industriel la recherche
universités du nord franche comté
il est urgent évidemment de redonner une
identité industrielle à notre nord
franche comté qui s'appuie sur nos deux
atouts l'énergie le transport à la fois
sur le ferroviaire l'automobile et
l'énergie celle d'aujourd'hui mais celle
que nous pourrons aussi de développer
demain avec le développement
renouvelables mathilde nassar quelle
marge de manoeuvre pour un ou une mère à
l'avenir par rapport à ces questions
industrielles
vous faites bien de le souligner parce
que la court terme sur jill clairement
c'est l'état qui a les clés en main pour
faire respecter ses engagements a dit
mais effectivement les élus le maire ne
fait que subir non pas du tout je vais
expliquer les élus locaux ils peuvent
créer on va dire des conditions
favorables pour l'industrie
je partage l'idée d'avoir un tissu
industriel comme celui qu'on a dans le
nord franche comté
c'est une chance mais ce tissu
industriel il est face à des mutations
extrêmement importante qu'il doit
réussir à faire dans le cadre notamment
de la transition écologique et il faut
l'accompagner pour cela en créant un
terrain extrêmement favorable en
articulant très étroitement les
questions d'industrie avec celle de la
recherche de l'enseignement et de
l'université et puisque le nord franche
comté est une terre de compétence on l'a
dit en matière d'automobile et puis
d'énergie nous on plaidera pour faire
installer comme a été installée il ya un
certain nombre d'années le crt à belfort
nationale de la recherche technologique
un commissariat national à l'hydrogène
justement et puis je rappelle qu'en plus
la ville de belfort peut aller dans ce
sens en par exemple utilisant une partie
de la flotte des véhicules en libre
service un optimaux pour les passer à
l'hydrogène et permettre ainsi des tests
et puis un développement de cette
technologie
damien meslot je vous laisse répondre
sur le maire aux abonnés absents
face à la crise à general electric et
aussi sur le centre d'affaires de la
jonction sur le centre d'affaires de
jonction nous avons lancé le centre jean
ctions 2 qui va créer de l'emploi
tout est vendu déjà et les gens qui
passent cialis les gens qui postent mais
madame madame madame hermine et la
commercialisation et lancer la deuxième
et vous nous expliquer tout jaber est ce
que vous pouvez avoir la correction vous
ne connaissez pas c'est qu'ils avaient
refait le problème
vous m'avez déjà posé une question
laissez moi répond sur le longue lançons
la jonction de ces 450 emplois qui vont
exister regarder ce qui se passe à
besançon et qui ne semble avoir misé et
qui ne sont pas remis non parce que sow
par la crise sanitaire a parce que le
diable ou parle d'eux je vous rappelle
qu'en matière d'industrialisation nous
avons réussi à obtenir le centre mondial
estime en matière d'hydrogène qui va
être un centre mondial de qualification
et de test pour les réservoirs
automobiles qui va être installé sur les
remarques de fontaine il y en a cinq
dans le monde
nous avons installé magnetto automotive
sur le thé club c'est 120 emplois d'un
grand sous traitants industriels de
l'automobile qui vient en italien il ya
1500 emplois sur deux plateformes
logistiques
les permis de construire déposés ou à
déposer sa vie et après on madame
chabert est ce que vous pouvez être un
peu moins agressive le cinéma gens
s'exprimer mais s'il dit aux belfortains
que c'est bien amazon manhattan à mme
chabert vailog qui a déposé son permis
de on a eu un ennui mais vous avez
toujours des à formater libération ces
6es
est-ce que vailog travaillera pour
amazon je n'en sais rien pour le moment
nous ne savons pas encore ce qui
s'esquisse et n'en savait rien il ya
1500 emplois qui vous écris moi sans je
trouve quand même
daniel hofer damien meslot les endroits
de vous annoncer par centaines et par
milliers depuis quelques mois
est ce que ne sont ils pas remise en
cause c'est une vraie question de fond
ne sont ils pas remise en cause et
menacés par la crise sanitaire
puisqu'on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui malgré ces dernières
semaines mais opposants quand une bonne
nouvelle pour bel fra sépare nos
opposants qui vous pose la question sans
nasri laisser un journal il échoue
où est réellement sens il s'en attriste
en revanche quand il ya des mauvaises
nouvelles il se réjouit soit celle
contre est ce que je peux vous dire sur
les emplois les 1500 emplois c'est que
le permis de construire a été déposé il
est il a été accepté
ces emplois vont venir et la crise de
magnetto automotive vous pouvez allez
voir ils ont commencé les prototypes n'a
fait le centre le centre ils savent y
aura tout le temps a promis le centriste
y aller on avait une on a une maison de
santé qui devait s'installer à belfort
mal à me chabert a dit cette maison de
santé il y aura j'avais 50 médecins à
les ôter club est en train de sortir de
terre
et on voit bien qui aura 50 médecins
paramédicaux l'étranger installer des
changes à la loi mais non il était de
nouveau et 30 sans sembler 37 ne sont
pas des classes mais bien sûr que non
vous avez les jardins du zèle qui
viennent c'est pas transfert ça vient de
l'extérieur vous pouvez prêcher le faux
mais au moins essayer de respecter
l'attractivité de belfort on dirait que
ça vous fait plaisir quand il ya des
mauvaises nouvelles
ma courbe et le nasr c'est la pêche les
rats lui ai donné que je voudrais oui
alors mais sheila rapidement bah oui
mais si vous m'interrogez pavot qui vous
adore ce que je voulais dire sur general
electric seco vient de lancer la
fiduciaire jeunes ministère de
l'économie au fil 50 millions d'euros
soit disposition de cette fille du ciel
qui sont versés par general electric et
qui vont servir à renforcer l'économie
locale
et ça c'est quelque chose d'important et
de co-créer mathilde nasa est ce que
vous êtes rassurés parce que vous venez
d'entendre pas complètement non en effet
moi je la création d'emplois c'est bien
mais quel emploi est ce qu'on propose
des emplois dans une plate forme type
amazon on sait bien ce que ces sont des
emplois précaires sont des conditions de
travail qui sont centrés sur la tonalité
des symboles one le taux de chômage
notamment dans les rangs même qui est le
plus important tout à fait de l'ensemble
de la bourgogne franche comté tout à
fait des emplois on peut en créer
autrement et la ville elle a vraiment
des clés en main pour faire ça par
exemple avec le plan isolation de 5000
logements qu'on propose on va créer
indirectement à grand nombre d'emplois
dans le secteur du bâtiment et de
l'artisanat puisque les chantiers vont
augmenter avec le fait de développer
l'agriculture urbaine les circuits
courts mais du bio dans les cantines
c'est aussi des domaines dans lesquels
on va créer de l'emploi avec le fait de
requalifier le quartier jean jaurès
dans lequel on souhaite poursuivre
l'expérience a commencé plus tôt
l'expérimentation
comment ces territoires 0 chômeurs de
longue durée
je ne crois pas ce qu'on peut faire sur
le quartier jean jaurès
on créera la en plus des emplois qui
sont complètement prise avec les besoins
du territoire
non s'il vous plaît ramage jones et des
destructions d'emplois aussi il faut le
savoir quand on crée un emploi avec les
plateformes on en détruit 2,5 dans le
commerce de proximité j'aimerais qu'on
entende mesdames messieurs les
belfortains l'une de nos équipes maximum
est nouveau et rémy points au son talent
et leur demander ce qu'ils attendaient
de leur future mère voici leurs réponses
on les écoute et on réagit tous ensemble
juste après y a rien ici
ici on est à la campagne en ici rien n'y
a pas d'attractions yarwun vous avez un
petit le week-end ou fait corps rien qui
prennent soin la ville qu'il ya un peu
plus de deux choses qui soient mis en
place surtout pour les jeunes parce que
du coup il n'y a pas énormément de
choses pour nous plus de commerces on
n'a plus de cheveux presque plus de
chaussures de magasins de chaussures
donc et puis des restaurations il n'y a
plus rien à belfort tous père ça devient
une ville bien triste je trouve ce que
fait des zones sensibles comme les
résidences et glacis je pense que c'est
des quartiers passé difficile et qui se
dégradent je trouve d'année en année et
je pense qu'il faudrait en priorité
s'occuper des des zones sensibles et
aussi du centre ville parce qu'ils se
dégradent aussi beaucoup sur tout
événement tous qui transporte à
l'ouverture des magasins etc
ça c'est important y'a rien on est à la
campagne on n'y a plus rien à belfort
c'est une ville bien triste est ce que
vous partagez ce constat samia jamais
ceux qui s'expriment dans la bouche des
belfortains c'est le sentiment du déclin
et je pense que ça on le re on le mesure
tous il ya en effet une inquiétude de
tous les belfortains quand on voit le
nombre de commerces qui ferment quand on
voit le peu d'attractivité que l'on a
développé pendant ce mandat et la
question est de savoir est-ce qu'il faut
continuer encore six ans comme cela
parce que le maire de belfort a été en
responsabilité pendant six ans il a
apporté aucun grand projet les
restructuration urbaine qui permettent
cette attractivité comme on a pu le
faire sur sur la vieille ville le lors
du précédent mandat
les la question des commerces on parle
beaucoup de commerces mais en fait on ne
fait pas grand chose on a créé une scène
récemment et après du sud économie une
société d'économie mixte et pas du tout
de réflexion d'ensemble et la question
de l'économie
elle revient aussi sur l'attractivité
parce que créer un véritable écosystème
du nord franche comté qui soit un espèce
de médine aire urbaine qui puisse
permettre de de montrer que l'on va
travailler pour créer les emplois de
demain
assurer la pérennité de l'existant et
préparez également l'avenir tout cela
nous ne l'avons pas vue pendant six ans
mathilde le mas à moi je dois quelque
chose qui m'interpelle sur la question
de les deux des quartiers on nous parle
des zones sensibles
mais à l'heure actuelle avant des
glaciers on a aidé résidence où est tout
à fait mais à l'heure actuelle
effectivement ce que disent les gens sur
ces quartiers je pense aux résidences en
particulier c'est qu'ils ont été
abandonnés que non seulement ils sont
abandonnés mais qu'en plus ils sont
stigmatisés que dès qu'il ya des
problèmes c'est eux qu'on vise
et c'est pour ça que je n'insisterai sur
cette actualité en plus on parle
beaucoup de la police
derniers temps la nécessité de remettre
en place une police de proximité forte
qui soit une police qui soit là pour
agir dans la prévention en
complémentarité avec les missions de la
police nationale recréer le lien entre
les habitants des quartiers recréer une
la dignité de ces jeunes qui se sentent
trop souvent stigmatisée c'est quelque
chose d'important cette police de
proximité vous modifier la mission de la
police municipale d'aujourd'hui comme on
voit là ce sont de nouveaux agents ont
l'art centre ça passe par une formation
évidemment importante tout le monde ne
s'improvise pas médiateur sur un
quartier ou plus près des eaux plus près
des gens ont la recentre sur des
missions de prévention à l'aide des
mairies de quartier que nous souhaitons
mettre en place pour créer au plus près
des gens dans les quartiers un tissu
d'acteurs de terrain qui seront des
référents qui pourront accompagner aussi
la vie du quartier joseph le nom mais je
crois que ce que l'on sent à travers ce
reportage en tout cas c'est un
délitement complet de la situation il ya
une véritable hémorragie on a perdu 3000
habitants à belfort c'est c'est quand
même j'allais dire assez parlant ce que
relate en fait nos concitoyens c'est ce
que l'on vit tous les jours
c'est cette tristesse que l'on retrouve
de plus en plus dans notre ville et
l'ont l'entente parfaitement dans ceux
qui par exemple pendant un an ne sont
pas venus à belfort habite le pourtour
proches à 80 100 km en 10 ans mais
belfort vous avait vieilli de 40 ans
d'un coup nokia véritable problème
d'urbanisme on n'a plus cette notion de
plaisir dans vie il ya un véritable
dépeuplement au niveau des commerces
je veux dire on parle beaucoup
d'économie circulaire d'économie
solidaire à belfort on a vraiment rien
de ce côté là mais tout simplement aussi
parce que je pense que il n'ya pas de
mains tendues vers tous ceux qui d'une
façon ou d'une autre travail à
l'économie de cette ville en sont la
richesse en sont le savoir ont les idées
et malheureusement tout est lié je veux
dire que quand vous perdez des habitants
ce sont parfois des services en moins
c'est une qualité de vie en moins et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut réapprendre
à travailler ensemble
ce n'est pas un seul homme qui doivent
décider depuis un bureau c'est un
ensemble c'est la formation
l'apprentissage les acteurs
socio-économiques pour refaire de
belfort une ville dynamique
mais cela ce que vous dirigez
aujourd'hui une ville en déclin comme
l'ont décrit nous avons décidé de lancer
une grande restructuration urbaine nous
rasons détour alors évidemment nous
avons raser des tours aux glacis aux
résidences s'entraînent une perte de la
population je donne d'ailleurs que quand
jean pierre chevènement avait fait la
même chose de l'autre côté du boulevard
kennedy belfort avait déjà passé sous la
barre des 50 mille habitants et à
l'époque j'ai gardé les articles de
presse on disait la même chose donc je
veux dire ce qu'on est en train de faire
c'est de restructurer complètement nous
rasons des tours aux résidences
nous reconstruisons de nouveaux
quartiers sur le monde sur la rue simone
veil à l'étang des forges sur l'ancien
site de l'hôpital mais tout ce qui se
fait en matière d'urbanisme
ça détend l'ont donc entre le moment où
on a acheté le site de l'hôpital il ya
six ans et le moment où nous
construisons où les logements sortent de
terre c'est-à-dire actuellement il ya
toujours une phase qui est une phase
difficile
et puis je voudrais dire si tout allait
si mal comment expliquez vous que les
belfortains et voté à 48% pour le maire
sortant dès le premier tour c'est quand
même assez étonnant qu'elle signifie
c'est quand même assez étonnant
voilà mais je pense c'est vrai mesdames
car c'est un argument assez imparable
je n'ai donc rien j'attends quand
j'entends les mails fartage ce n'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes ccoc ce que
j'entends à la colle sur ta je vous
assure qu'il ya mes collègues sont allés
dans la rue et ya pas de montage à
charge ou à décharge je ne sais pas si
j'ai dit mais le cheveu je veux dire
c'est qu'il ya quand même eu un certain
nombre de belfortain qui se sont
exprimés sur le bilan qui était le bilan
du maire sortant
et quand on veut nous expliquer que
quand on nous explique que tout va mal
48% comme toulouse explique que tout va
mal je pense qu'il faut prendre un petit
peu et puis j'attends les propositions
concrètes de l'opposition qui critique
toujours mais qui me propose jamais
samia j'avais en justement que proposez
vous attendais parce que on a parlé des
quartiers on a parlé aussi de la police
et éventuellement de la police de
proximité sur ces questions là quelles
sont vos propositions
puisque monsieur le maire veut des
proposé sur les câbles au camp
clairement mais selon à abandonner les
quartiers
il a fait aucun face le moment
aujourd'hui sur les lions jour donne la
parole aux glacis de dimanche c'était
désespérant
là le la saleté qui adore le quartier
les sentiments d'abandon est vraiment
très très profond
non rien n'a été fait sur les quartiers
en matière de golfeurs attendait le shaq
chaque question en son temps les
quartiers que faut-il faire
après on parle à la police si vous
écoutez les restructurations ont été
mises à l'arrêt parce que monsieur mes
sauts parle du renouvellement le cheveu
cieux mais se parle du renouvellement
urbain les démolitions c'est pas lui qui
les a faits j'en avais déjà qui était
prévu au moment où il est arrivé il a en
effet fait des démolitions sur le
secteur des résidences
mais où en est le projet de
réaménagement du quartier
il est à l'arrêt aujourd'hui le jury
nous a mené en bateau pendant cinq ans
pour nous dire si j'attends les
challenges bien sûr il ya eu la piste
j'attends les les fonds de l'état et les
terrains sauf qu'entre temps en six ans
les habitants du quartier ne voit rien
arriver et nous devons remettre dans les
quartiers nous devons remettre
nous devons remettre nous devons
remettre des services en matière
d'éducation le périscolaire monsieur
mesto la supprimer les ateliers
périscolaires gratuit pour lui les a
supprimées si vous avez également
supprimés vous avez supprimé l'éducation
populaire vous avez mis sous cloche
finir et la parole circule qui me plaît
vous avez mis les centres socioculturels
sous votre tutelle est aujourd'hui se
sont vidés de toute activité
voilà le résultat aujourd'hui dans l'ide
et des quartiers il ya une totale
déshérence en matière de police
alzheimer en matière de police puisque
on parle aussi de la question de la
sécurité
je pense qu'il ya un véritable bilan
d'échec sur la police de monsieur muscle
il a triplé les effectifs de la police
minutie des maristes municipal est-ce
que les délits ce sont onze disparus
le nombre de quad de mobylettes qui
dérange au quotidien qui harcèlent les
habitants des quartiers
je n'ai encore vu constaté dimanche au
glacier pour une police de proximité est
importante pour justement sortir
la police purement sécuritaire monsieur
vincent comment nous allons organiser
oui monsieur mais sow nous a organisé la
guerre des polices il ya quelques
semaines il a si vous avez rompu le
contrat avec la police nationale cherche
une irresponsabilité encore un courrier
de l'alcoolisme qui nous remercient pour
de telles opérations vous aidant on vous
on ne comprend rien on ne comprend rien
marie josé fleury sur la politique des
quartiers et la police s'il vous plaît
la politique des quartiers écouter on
parle des glacis on parle des résidences
c'est vrai il n'ya plus aucun service il
ya des immeubles de plus en plus en
mauvais état mais j'évoquerai aussi
bushnell où j'étais il ya deux jours on
voit des voitures brûlées qui traînent
sur les parkings très franchement même
ce quartier qui est au coeur du centre
ville devient salle très sale en plus je
rappellerai juste il ya une résidence
universitaire la résidence sartre je
dire qui est tagué enfin vous savez très
souvent l'attractivité d'une ville elle
se fait aussi à travers son logement
pour les étudiants
aujourd'hui vouloir faire de belfort une
ville étudiante et attirer de nouvelles
formations j'en doute quand je vois
l'état où on les familles viennent en
premier dans une ville je veux dire j'ai
été scotché ça ne vous ça ne vous
inquiète pas ça ne vous interroge pas
une maladie l'année d'une ville que l'on
que j'ai moi je suis l'échelon l'est
tout autant et c'est pour ça monsieur
monsieur parce que si on habitait pas
belfort si on ne travaillait pas à
belfort on était les bras tout cela
devant ses traits mais ce cas ce que
vous dites monsieur meslot j'ai toujours
mon appartement en ville
j'habite à belfort je travaille à
belfort j'ai mes enfants belfort je vais
quand même pas non plus me justifier
donc voila voila merci même jamais je
l'avais je veux c'est quand même un
croyant c'est donne à voir la sécurité
il est vrai que belfort
on le ressent là aussi chez les
belfortains devient de plus en plus
insécurisant on a d une police
municipale qui doit être recentrée sur
ses missions
parce qu'aujourd'hui la seule mission
qu'elle a c'est la verbalisation l
occupation du domaine public c'est bien
peu pour une ville qui encore une fois
est en déclin et subit de plus en plus
vers ces sites a bien mais selon je vous
laisse répondre le ville n'est pas du
tout en déclin quant à la police lui
alors il vient démographique au moins 20
des beaux graphiques bien sûr puisque
amour nous avons raser des tours et nous
allons reconstruire
évidemment on enlève les gens voient de
raser les tours donc ça fait baisser la
population et lorsque et lorsque l'on
reconstruit et lorsque le hainaut gris
et lorsque l'on reconstruit on ramène
des habitants riaj elle donne
rendez-vous dans quelques années vous
verrez que la population va revenir
quant à la police municipale les délits
ont baissé de 75% chiffres du ministère
de l'intérieur
donc on voit bien que la police fait son
travail pour en revenir aux quads
je vous signale que les quads ne peuvent
être confisqués que sur l'action du
procureur de la république qui nous en a
confisqué un certain nombre mais c'est
extrêmement difficile de lutter contre
les quads parce que la loi est très
restrictive et très souvent que de la
police nationale ou municipale
interpellent des quads et bien on n'a
pas les moyens juridiques de les
confisquer ce qui pose souci est le
problème des quads n'existe pas depuis
uniquement à belfort est uniquement de
comptes chez super u de maurice voilà
mathilde nasa sur la sécurité
vous avez initié l'idée d'une police de
proximité tout à l'heure vous fait le
même constat que samia jaber sur comment
dire
le divorce avec la police nationale je
veux pas voilà à la guerre des polices
en tout cas j'irais pas aussi - moi je
continue à dire qu'il faut une
complémentarité fortes se sont pas les
mêmes missions
ce ne sont pas les mêmes missions donc
je j'ai parlé de la police de proximité
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui me
semble utile à faire très rapidement
rapproché le on a quand même un gros
problème de lien social en général et
j'irai même plus loin on a un problème
d'isolement à belfort une famille sur
deux est une famille d'une seule
personne en fait il ya 48 % des
belfortains qui vivent seules
le lien social il se reconstruit par
énormément de choses la police de
proximité en est une partie une partie
seulement
mais il faut travailler aussi sur tous
les autres aspects et ça la question de
la lutte contre l' isolement moi il me
semble essentiel et alors ça c'est un
constat mais la lutte contre l'
isolement qu'est ce que vous proposez
alors ça va sur plusieurs
domaine puisque moi je considère que
tout ça est très l'ensemble des choses
sont liées
les mairies de quartier dont je parlais
pour rapprocher des services des
habitants
travailler avec les acteurs de terrain
et puis les auprès des mairies de
quartier nous souhaitons mettre en place
des conseillers citoyens indépendants
pour que les gens du quartier soient
plus impliqués qu'on écoute leur avis
qu'on décide pas au centre-ville de tout
ce qui va passer de tout ce qui va se
passer par exemple dans les quartiers et
puis on a parlé effectivement des
résidences et des glaces il souhaite
mettre la lumière un petit peu aussi sur
le quartier jean jaurès qui est un
quartier qui connaît des difficultés
avec un logement par exemple de plus en
plus insalubres
nous on souhaite faire un projet
particulier sur ce quartier un projet
pilote d'une nouvelle politique urbaine
qui réussissent à allier l'ensemble de
ces dispositifs où on travaillera sur le
commerce sur le transport ça a été
soulignée par une des personnes qu'on a
entendu tout à l'heure sur le cadre de
vie en général sur l'emploi avec gilet
évoqué tout à l'heure l'expérimentation
territoire zéro chômeur de longue durée
donc pour faire ce test là sur ce
quartier qu'on pourra après appliqué aux
autres quartiers de la ville damien
meslot on a évoqué les quartiers alors
c'est aussi un peu symptomatiques de
suite ça a glissé sur la police de
proximité sur le rôle d'amortisseur
social de la vie dans un contexte
économique général qui peut être très
tendu
qu'est-ce qu'on quelles sont les marges
de manoeuvre encore là une fois du mais
les marges de manoeuvre sont importantes
c'est l'emploi c'est l'apprentissage
nous avons augmenté fortement le nombre
d'apprentis qui sont accueillis à la
ville nous aidons les jeunes à passer
leur permis de conduire nous payons 75%
du prix du permis de conduire à des
jeunes pour leur permettre d'accéder à
l'emploi en échange de 81 eur qui sont
donnés à des associations caritatives
dans la ville de belfort bref nous avons
toute une série d'actions qui tourne
autour de notre service jeunesse de
notre ccs pour aider les gens et tout
cela nous vous offrons beaucoup de
stages d'insertion nous aidons un
certain nombre nous avons la mif enfin
nous avons tout eu tout un panel de
mesures qui sont là pour aider les gens
dans leurs difficultés
et ça ça va encore se développer avec la
crise du que vides alors mesdames
messieurs on arrive déjà au terme de ce
débat je vais vous proposer à chacune à
chacun 40 secondes pour conclure que
souhaitez vous dire aux belfortains qui
vôtre
dimanche dans cinq jours pour les
convaincre de voter pour vous samia
jaber c'est vous qui commencez 45 ans de
conclusion suivi j'aimerais dire aux
belfortains que les compteurs ont été
remis à zéro que sur les vingt-quatre
mille inscrits sur la ville de belfort
4000 seulement ont fait le choix de
renouveler la confiance à damien meslot
4000 sur vingt-quatre mille donc en
effet tout est jouable tout peut être
rejouer lors de cette élection c'est une
nouvelle élection dans une nouvelle
période avec une élection à un tour
je voudrais dire aussi aux belfortains
que dès le lendemain de cette élection
il faudra une équipe solide qui soit en
capacité de se mettre au travail tout de
suite parce qu'il faudra voter le budget
il faudra préparer
très vite la rentrée scolaire avec le
nombre de décrocheurs scolaires pendant
cette pandémie
la collectivité locale devra mettre les
moyens pour les familles pour les
parents pour faire que cette rentrée se
met ainsi au mieux mieux jaber votre
conclusion maria josé fleury s'il vous
plaît oui j'appelle en tout cas tous les
belfortaines et tous les belfortains le
28 juin à voter pour notre liste qui je
le rappelle est ce la seule liste à
pouvoir rassembler très largement pour
porter un nouveau projet un projet
d'avenir en tout cas pour nos
concitoyens pour une ville qui doit être
plus dynamique plus durable et surtout
plus sûr
merci marie josé fleury mathilde nassar
votre conclusion s'il vous plaît alors
une autre ville est non seulement
possible mais elle est surtout
nécessaire parce que les épreuves qui
nous attendent seront redoutables
on peut pas se permettre de perdre
encore six ans nous avons été placés
deuxièmes au soir du premier tour et
c'est un formidable espoir pour belfort
puisque la solution la connaît c'est
l'écologie populaire l'écologie
populaire qui est en passe de remporter
les grandes villes de notre pays
strasbourg lille toulouse bordeaux par
exemple il faut pas qu'on rate ce
rendez-vous pour belfort alors si on
veut protéger notre ville nos vies celle
de nos enfants et la planète
j'invite les gens à voter 2020 en commun
pour belfort merci mathilde nassar
dernière mais selon votre conclusion
s'il vous plaît j'appelle les
belfortaines et les belfortains se
mobiliser rien n'est joué
nous sommes arrivés largement en tête
mais rien n'est joué donc il faut se
mobiliser
les belfortains ont vu au cours des six
années qui se sont écoulées la politique
que nous avons menée pour m belfort dans
une direction
plus plus importante pour donner un
autre fils plus de sécurité plus de
dynamisme plus d'attractivité et je les
invite à continuer dans cette voie merci
beaucoup merci à tous les quatre d'être
venus débattre bonne fin de campagne il
reste donc cinq jours dimanche nous
votons pour les élections municipales le
deuxième tour dans un instant
l'information en région avec adrien gave
a dit demain 18 heures on continue à
bouleverser nos programmes avec les deux
candidats à la mairie de lons le saunier
dans le jura et puis je dis je recevrai
sur ce plateau
les trois finalistes pour l'élection
municipale à besançon à la capitale
comtoise merci beaucoup de votre
fidélité à france 3 franche comté la
chaîne de vos élections régionales
merci beaucoup on reste en place on est
donc
[Musique]